you ready for Freddy now that's a
[ __ ] bong it greetings from podcast
Ville the Church of what's happening now
is brought to you by on it listen to me
when it comes to supplements then I
[ __ ] around there contest is over for
them alpha brain you [ __ ] up and now
they got the six weeks challenge that
you should have joined you [ __ ] up
gonna on it
stay in touch of what they're doing
subscribe to the news weather even if he
just do that but if you're thinking you
slippin lately a memory by Papa Papa
Papa alpha brain is the way to go it's
their [ __ ] satellite [ __ ] product
why 100% money-back guarantee and they
don't want the product back nobody else
does that to business okay so go [ __ ]
yourself go to how to calm right now
press in church boom and get 10% off
your [ __ ] order right and with
that said the great and powerful my
brother mr. Dean Dell rizzi is in studio
today along with the [ __ ] what
is it there Johnny no sugar
oh man before we even start the show
where we started the show but I want to
say happy birthday to you thank my
[ __ ] brother right there thank you my
brother
50 born on the same day Bon Scott died
so you just totally took the reins and
rolled and I still remember that winter
[ __ ] Oh day well he died I did a hit
acid it was a great day oh and then we
end of the day with finding out Paul Bon
Scott it died that's not you were born
on the day Bon Scott died I was born on
the day Buddy Holly Big Bopper and
Richie Valens died so we're just a
couple of guys is carrying the bad luck
yeah we're carrying the torch still man
now you know why don't go to Vegas great
man it feels [ __ ] surreal I remember
the first time I heard that that was
your birthday we were like on the road
or something
wait a minute
this is de banda yeah I'll never forget
your birthday [ __ ] crazy yeah that's
crazy how I'll even know I got in yeah
I'm living on 5757 I'm living the life
of that guy in that Talking Heads
commercial you know that that that song
I like get here like that every day
yeah every day I Drive around I'm like
holla end up in California like
sometimes you take child for me for
granted you know right and you see a
[ __ ] palm tree oh you ain't gonna
[ __ ] am i yeah like what the [ __ ]
happened I was just in a [ __ ] jail in
Colorado you know I was just getting
processed I thought my life was over him
surround they will [ __ ] palm trees so
bright yes the hub of it man life is a
[ __ ] journey in half man yeah and
it's so weird how you have to give it a
chance and just have a little bit of
hope and your [ __ ] down I mean that's
basically it I mean as much as they say
it sounds corny it's not a sprint it's a
it's a marathon it's so real cuz each
year you keep going you gonna sound
remember one time somebody said
something to me that I said nothing to
happen and they said oh it was Ian
Edwards and he said well did you do
Conan last year I go now yes did you do
did we pass to the comedy so last year I
know I guess well then it's happening
you know you just forget cuz you're just
in it every day and then you go you're
right man I'm just each year getting a
little further and still in it which is
awesome
how old do you feel like if you had to
guess like if you woke up do you think
you'd be 18 yeah how old do I feel me
honestly I feel about 44 yeah yeah I
feel about 44 45 you know III tomorrow
I'm gonna make a date for the physical
my knee hurts you know I have a rule
tendonitis in my right shoulder
I still have good energy yeah I do feel
the fifties surge of testosterone I read
about you have two surgeries a day as a
man and you have to ride them you know
that's why I know I have to worry work
out early if I don't do my [ __ ] early
I'm not gonna do it right I lie to
myself every night and I sat here and
lied to you guys two weeks ago I have
God to do Jitsu just could not go at
night
yeah there's no I've even tried to hit
the bag at night like said to myself at
8 o'clock I'm gonna go in the backyard
for years that was my favorite thing was
to get high at night put some music on
and [ __ ] punch the [ __ ] out of a bag
yeah I'd nominate hey take it you do 30
minutes on a bag every night the fat
falls right off here it falls right off
it you see it within two weeks just the
first two weeks of punching yeah you
burn a bunch of baby fat off your arms
and you'll increase the speed any
punches for years that was my thing was
go ahead a garage and Boulder I had a
backyard in Aspen yeah
in basalt we had a backyard and it was
connected to a tree and at night that
eight o'clock law when people were
watching TV I get super [ __ ] I always
figured out I always had a ghetto
blaster yeah or something I wrapped my
hands there was some nights for years
with him that bunch of bad gloves I just
wrapped my hands with the wrap two wraps
yeah and I just hit the bag and that's
how I stayed in the shade
there's nights I'm like I'm gonna want
it tonight eight o'clock at the back
[ __ ] I open up the door I'm so scared
it's dark out there I'm not going out
there so
that time I feel if I were taking care
of myself in my thirties the way I'm
taking care of myself now without a
different game for you guys listen take
care yourselves in your thirties that's
a crucial crucial point of your life
it's very
crucial and set you up you know a lot of
these get people get cancer 38 42 that's
correct I don't [ __ ] around
take this yeah I lost control of my life
at 36 I lost control of my life at 16
yeah but the real world
loss of control was when I moved here
because of my love and passion for
comedy you know I wasn't gonna live the
Joe Rogan lifestyle I wasn't living
Lenny Bruce lifestyle Yeah right all
right Richard Pryor he's not taking
Kerry so eating whatever eating whatever
you know and I wish I would have done
different you asked me I wish I would
join the army you know yeah we showed it
though a lot of things yeah you could
join the army come on when you're 38
still get into comedy yeah and at 48 be
a [ __ ] star with a pension you know I
mean so who the [ __ ] [ __ ] up here
right now I still had a pension not much
insurance people saluting me at the
[ __ ] [ __ ] I [ __ ] up yeah but you
know some somebody tell him that boxing
was saying that their friend [ __ ]
watch the stand-up special he goes it's
his on the way out he was gonna ask you
a question a personal question I go yeah
hi I know you're a stand-up because a
friend of a friend of a friends we went
to a party Sunday and we've seen her
quit her job at 45 to get into stand-up
and I just loaded my bag up what do you
think of that I go happens all the time
and he goes but why would somebody wait
I go because they didn't know what they
really wanted out of this [ __ ] life
yeah one day they clocked in and said
just it's like a punch to the head so I
get knocked out like what am I doing
here I just want to be in a car with
dual responsibilities you know my cards
are paid for I have nothing to lose I
got 50,000 credit I'm going for it yeah
you know and she's like that's ogwuche
plant that's it a finance to hoe comedy
career and she hopes she makes them I go
those are the people that make it yeah
you roll the dice people like no [ __ ] it
we gotta take care of the [ __ ] gamble
on yourself from time to time you gotta
take a [ __ ] chance
Columbus it makes life more interesting
yeah you know I was talking to my
neighbor yeah I got off the [ __ ]
plane and I I got dropped off in Burbank
and uh I saw my neighbor outside he was
way he coming from the hills Tempe and
he goes how long have you been doing
this for cause he always sees me coming
home on Sunday yeah and we usually just
say hello he goes where'd you go this
weekend but this time he came over this
guy's [ __ ] in you ever seen my
neighbor no I've only heard stories the
old man I have a couple different
neighbors but this guy is the old man I
met the woman the one that knows the
rockers that's what I was but that's
okay yeah
his my husband's gotta be 78 Wow wait do
you guys see him beside his white hair
you don't know he's 78 Oh Jack Owen and
shame I write because she's always
moving oh yeah you know me Tony's not
wake up in the morning to take trash out
and he's digging a trench and I'm gonna
computer tweet and go [ __ ] your mother
oh my god anyway enough unless you
listen I only congratulate you on your
podcast no you really kicked it up to
the next level even though nobody's
noticing I'm [ __ ] to know this all
right now you called me I agree feels so
good the guys Kirk Hammet current habit
you know people wrote articles about it
I mean I was actually pissed you can
hear it in my voice that day that has
pissed that you are there you're up the
old Eddie trunk in these guys you're
really there and serious isn't reaching
out while him isn't reaching up none of
these people reaching out but there's
two sides that coin
yeah that could be a blessing in
disguise now or you could use it as or
whatever you know
I mean you're getting guests there that
most radio people don't get on and and
it's not even that people there's a
podcast I don't know you're great guys
great guys great podcast and they were
reaching out to one guy constantly and I
said don't define your podcast by a
guest yeah don't ever define your
podcast by I guess but if you do get him
make the best of them and always have
those guests lined up you know I hate
these people I contact you and they go
do my podcast and also and you want to
do that podcast but you look at the
numbers then again then you go all I'm
gonna do is spike their numbers for a
week and then it's gonna go down again
you have to have a plan if you call me
and say listen I'm getting you on them
behind you I'm getting the guy from this
band behind you I'm getting this actor
at least you get a chance to spike in it
yeah review some spike your podcast form
alright yes for one guess it's not worth
the aggravation of you chasing that one
gas line up 20 of them and then attack
you don't say ain't [ __ ] reach out
the publicist do them this morning I was
reaching up Oh [ __ ] publicist yeah you
know that's true it you've got a do
sometimes and they don't mean your back
yeah they don't hit your back but you're
opening up the universe for somebody
else to hear you know hey my friend is a
fan of the show
you mind if he's on you're like no yeah
yeah yeah yeah but I see what you're
doing I just really want to congratulate
you oh man thank you sad [ __ ] [ __ ] go
from Aerosmith on yeah just aren't
regular [ __ ] yes these superstars
these are [ __ ] legends that you
getting on yeah I wish that your numbers
really growing your fan base is growing
and you know I mean when it comes to
music I tell everybody you're the best
wow thanks when it comes to music
because I dropped off yeah you kept on I
dropped off I got caught up in comedy
and cocaine and it divorces yeah yeah
yeah and you still remain loyal to the
you still gonna Roxy you still go you
know you go to the edge of hell to see a
show still I think you know that's what
kept me kept me young you know it's
constantly searching for the new the new
band the new great film the new great
car or whatever how old do you feel
right now you know my mind I feel like
I'm constantly about 35 but I don't know
in the last couple of years I feel like
90 also at the same time just I'm pretty
tired a lot and then my neck my neck was
[ __ ] up
still still rehabbing it and the crash
those three things really kind of took
me out and also I think I just worked so
much I'm not resting properly you know
like seven days a week so I'm always
tired but other than that my mind and my
my enthusiasm is definitely like 35
listen when you go to med school yeah my
niece is in med school I talked to a
mother all the time all the time me and
Lisa talk all the time these kids spend
hours a day study yeah you know they
they get crammed like over you get so
much material thrown that chair whatever
they're in that 20s I know for a fact
she was telling me that my niece goes to
bed wake 11:00 and gets up at 4 to get
to work hours of studying there there's
something like that it's the same thing
with common guy yeah it's the same thing
with anything that you want to make work
it's not eight hours no not at all
what are you talking about it's let's do
whatever you need to you know it's so
weird how the best two hours of work I
get it now tonight from 9:30 to 11:00
I'll get him more work than most people
doing today yep I'll send out 20 emails
you know this more yesterday yesterday
had this [ __ ] I had to go left at 10th I
think I got up at 7 between 7 and 10 I
did more than most people doing a week
yeah I left the house I had already sent
out emails fly is [ __ ] and shortages
you know Instagram and it's like people
have no idea you know do you prepare the
night before like before I go to bed
have a little notebook and everything's
checked off totally
what music I'm putting up the next day
yeah yeah you know what I heard that
brought me back I mean everything's a
[ __ ] written down because it's a plan
of attack it's like a [ __ ] I'm laying
out my groundwork for the [ __ ] day
who I have to call you know I read they
have a thing I have to do something for
myself so I look at that what am I gonna
do for me tomorrow
tomorrow I'm gonna write an hour I
always have an hour of a goal to write
right but I always in the right three
hours yeah yeah Tommy still how many
times you go to conversate with nine
o'clock spot you get in your car at
12:30 oh you know every time every
[ __ ] time every time triple e I saw
him today's then I put y'all HIO trips
no late shows yeah because I'm walking
around at 12:30 bed till 2:00
yeah and I'm walking around the next
morning at 7:00 kissing some kid getting
on lunch ready I can't [ __ ] do it
yeah I can't do it no more you know it's
amazing I cannot do it no more if you
have you want me to be your second show
you're gonna have a problem you gotta
put me up either first second or third I
gotta be out of there by 11:30 and even
then it takes you 15 minutes to get to
your car oh yeah in Parkton live in
drive-bys
yeah and then at the parking lot you
don't know who the [ __ ] you're gonna see
yeah awesome Bob Saget wants to talk you
haven't seen him in 20 years yeah damn
it yeah and yet the night you got mad
cuz you have to talk to him but now
you're stuck there now are you get in
there you were just about ready to leave
but not three cars pulled up Dave
Chappelle yes
well how would you gotta go pull out now
they're gonna go get Dave and his
[ __ ] keys to his rock and the cousin
and the brother had a [ __ ] nightmare
people have no idea I love when he comes
because I know we're gonna talk
motorcycles we'll talk a little music
you know it's like I'll see him it'll be
like a Dean man what you read you know
like he loves motorcycles so I know I'm
not getting out of there for a while you
know I never see him
oh man never see him Oh whenever I see
and they'll tell me he's upstairs yeah
yeah
about ready go upstairs he just
announced the show two hours ago yeah it
sold out already that might what love it
man he's like my favorite how does the
amount shows on Twitter no there's an
app doesn't have Twitter the venue's the
venue's do so I guess they just call and
say we want to go on tomorrow night and
then the venue will just drop it like an
hour before he just did that at the
chapel I'm doing the chapel next Tuesday
in San Fran it's like a church I'm doing
it Wednesday and he was in San Fran he's
like yeah just let's do some comedy and
I did like four shows or something why
he was there just over the weekend all
sold out instantly people jumping out of
their cars running to the venue
I gotta get tickets that's how I was
when I bought a ticket for him at the
store when he first got back from Africa
I just saw they were putting the name up
on the marquee Dave and I saw ch I
pulled over hey what's going on I wasn't
doing comedy I think oh yeah she fell
tonight you can get a ticket right now I
just ran over there bought a ticket
couldn't believe it I love with new eyes
hear that on Twitter but it's like from
three hours ago I got sold out yeah I
got he's he is a I got the dream to make
dream career he's I called him recently
like the Zeppelin of comedy yes because
he's got crazy mystique and he doesn't
have any social media he doesn't do any
TV appearances like clips yeah he's not
going on doing you know Tonight Show or
any of that it's just it's just ninja
guerrilla comedy and then it's people
just go crazy for it I love it that's
the dream that's a dream gig right there
and he's funny every [ __ ] time man
every tack that he has no social media I
love that and look you know if you look
at the big guys in Tommy excuse and
Rogen but Sebastian social media isn't
big no and neither is game you know for
the tickets itself right you know
Gabriel sells out [ __ ] huge amounts
of problems yeah
and didn't he just do like the staples
like yeah multiple knives they gave his
own parking spot yeah I love that I'm so
proud of I had him on last weekend it
was [ __ ] great amazing really was
just nice to see you know the thing
about comedy clubs and comics is
sometimes you see each other the ones
that you really like yeah you just
bumped to and passing at the store then
you feel guilty that time the way home
that you didn't ask him how his family
was getting Congressional another film
that you might have seen a model right
commercially you might have seen a man
or so that's what pisses me off about
just seeing comics like I have to store
sometimes it's nice to do a podcast at
them get him away from the comedy club
and just talk them even like us yeah
unless we go on the road
I don't really [ __ ] see you them on
the other side of the town you know I
see if this profile wall yeah on the way
in 10 minutes three minutes yeah and
you're like I think you're up next and
suck and I run inside then I may see you
yeah your gun then you're on there not
while you're on I'm on in the other room
yeah it's crazy yeah but uh no I just
want to really applaud you on the job
you told with you podcasting that thank
you suck it out what a lot of people
would have given up and I could see big
things happening for the podcast it just
it's just obvious yeah yeah I got to
move that thing to like Sirius XM you
know I've been meeting with him for like
three years
and it's just on and off the same thing
over and over let's have a meeting we
have a meeting we eat and then I'm like
what happened there okay what were we
talking about I mean these guests are
huge
you got five hundred and sixteen
episodes a back log that you can put on
your show they're not promotion things
they're they're actual long term
long-form conversations so you can use
those it's it's it's hours and hours of
of material it's crazy when you I was
thinking about of a person
yeah they kid I moved since he was a
doorman at the store yeah I still am
losing a ton of weight he won a specific
diet but I really admire he would bring
his own food wrapped they told me he was
weighing that the portions and they I
really got into him nice white kid you
could tell he was raised right he went
to a great college and he became a
regular MIT's he passed them and he
wasn't the type of guy to go and this is
why I tell people comedy is such a weird
journey but this is a weird story today
this is and I don't mean this in an
undone appreciative what I've known this
guy for 20 [ __ ] years you know those
people that take you to lunch and
nothing happens yeah the people who are
not in this industry or whatever don't
understand you're gonna I don't know if
plumbers just take each other out yeah
blow smoke in your ass yeah not
electricians yeah
cops take each other out to blow smoke
in their ass and this business you'll
get this guy and he'll call you up and
he'll go hey I'm hearing great things
about you and we have some projects
coming up and we'd like to use you can I
buy you lunch and I'd meet him like
[ __ ] places where you'd only you know
I down less Cienega yeah wouldn't it
gets towards the will [ __ ] oh he would
make me meet him there and I was 400
pounds I gotta walk a half-mile from the
free parking garage yeah cuz I didn't
have the money to pay for the real
parking like regular people yeah have
that those free Santa Monica parking
places yeah and I don't normally [ __ ]
times I met him and for years he just
moved from completed company and it was
always we have exciting things I would
go on the web page and two days later
I'd see a picture of Leon there and he's
had lunch with you yeah well my video
it's just it's just 20 [ __ ] years
every three years I got a call from him
yeah and it's always a new company and
my name came up in the meeting and I got
a free lunch out of the deal yeah at
first that's kind of cool
you're like ah man I'm gonna eat the
[ __ ] flaming yarn I'm getting two
sides you know yeah and it just got old
and about six years ago I said that's it
I'm with this guy
yeah I know and I saw him one night yeah
you don't
he goes from me to do lunch I'm on a new
company I know it's great you know here
we go again
I you know why only last Friday oh I got
an email from him and he's like listen
we want you to tell the story we usually
pay people this but we're gonna pay you
this if you really try we could pay you
this and like it was like you know I
don't want to say it was no money
basically yeah yeah me twenty two
[ __ ] years yeah six dollars for 600
hours pays 200 but you get you four but
you could probably ask them for six
twenty-two years eight hours of lunches
I was a [ __ ] lunch mm and get out
like people have no idea what's day
what's the other guy that guy you know
the roller skating guy who was us at
Night Live he had a movie they had a bag
of [ __ ] last weekend with roller skating
guy what's the movie the bag of [ __ ]
with Julia Dreyfuss last week oh oh he
was in charge of content over there oh
yeah that's funny guy when I was Joey
karate yeah he [ __ ] took me out to
lunch they were smoking my cigarettes
like we're gonna [ __ ] you're gonna be
the biggest thing I'll do or die put all
your videos yeah me in the back with
[ __ ] black people would [ __ ] yeah
people protesting huh and nuclear waste
oh I'm like what the [ __ ] yeah I thought
you my body
I don't eat Jimmy yeah every morning I
get up at 5:00 and my feet chin there'd
be a fat [ __ ] dude
bongos I'm on the ninth page I was I was
really joke
ah like I was really joke yeah yeah
anyways somewhere else and he played me
again with the Joey karate videos listen
leave joint karate 11 by hung up on them
did you just gonna aggravate me 9 years
to get the 600 [ __ ] down oh well you
know I don't I I love it it's part of
the game and everything but I also I
always wonder what they're doing are
they do they are they telling their
bosses yeah what do you got going you're
not really doing anything well I've got
a meeting with Dean Del Ray on Thursday
and we're gonna talk about this and then
that I don't know if they were just
doing it to show their boss or they're
waiting
he might get giant let's keep keep them
in the mix you know let's meet with him
once every four or five months in case
it gets giant and you know they do the
old bleep we've always loved you okay
slide you know but you know like people
were always asking me why do you want to
be on XM radio so bad your podcast is
doing good and it's it's I I like I love
XM radio and I'm thinking well I did
want one and also for healthcare but now
I got healthcare thanks to you you're
giving me the tip of hate go down there
sang and talk to him
but there's something about it just you
know one day I feel like somebody's got
to take Howard Stern's place
you know there's if he retires he's got
this army of people and they should
start grooming people wanna do talk or
do you wanna do way I mean music I like
to do talk like I'm doing on the podcast
now interviews so you also get to see
the comedic side of me some funny stuff
and that kind of thing you know I'm not
interested in being a DJ or anything
like that I want to be like a guy like a
stern but also be able to do comedy
every night I want to try to get to a
theater level comic not I don't want
arenas I want to be able to be on a bus
do theatres and that during the day be
doing this radio
show that's what I wanted five days a
week oh yeah sure man if it's like you
know something like a stern format
couple hours five days a week like the
LA serious I wanted to be I wanted to do
the three to five you know or the noon
to three one of those two spots so I
could be out all night doing comedy and
then I get up get ready go interview
some people
I can't Steve Jonesy's jukebox man what
a great great format he has a couple
interviews play some great music and
you're out of there I think he's noon to
2:00 what a dream I do you think and I
know it's hard to deal with this while
you're waiting to blow up but to me it
seems like there's a lot of room for
music to blow up and podcasting like how
it comedians really took it over these
musicians have so many stories I'm some
problem of surprises isn't big referring
musicians
well they're stunned I mean Tom Morello
just got a show on Sirius it's great
we're just talking about Kagan's got a
show there's a few let's start but now
they're starting to go out more yeah and
no listen altered today today at some
point I think it's Ozzy Duff somebody
else doing an interview on Aziz new
ordinary man song yeah gotta cancel a
tour so yeah if you listen like I go on
Sirius a lot in the car yeah in the same
hair it's amazing how John's got the
station's really Joe's got a sterile Jam
Pearl Jam about the station Bruce Bruce
has a station and they probably do it
from their house and send it in
you know I'm not sure if they're in the
studio I don't know don't quote me yeah
but more people are doing it I mean I
want to do something if I did something
on Sirius
Dean I've always liked that a little
late-night dude oh yeah at 9:00 to 12:00
do yeah that 9:00 to 12:00 do it has to
have a certain voice oh yeah Jim lad
remember him Jim lad
I have a certain coolness tall yeah a
certain feel when I was a kid we had a
guy on a black radio station and he is
the voice is very this nextgen
really good it's he odd so you know Don
Cornelius town Don Cornelius town didn't
even though all right there was WBLS and
he used to go I gotta take two steps to
the rear and get out yeah yeah yeah I'm
in the wind later yeah yeah I said now
Reverend Ike used to come on you could
be what you wanna be yeah do what you
wanna do or say what you want to say
just send remember in 93 dollars a month
and I'll send you some black holy water
I'll change my night at 10 o'clock the
guy came on Reverend Ike that's rich
ever the switch over but that's what I
like to do something like that but
anyway all [ __ ] golds aside yeah the
real reason I wanted to talk to you was
something that happened that was weird
for you and I because we both grew up
with these bands and it was the [ __ ]
Hall of Fame snobs this year which I
usually never care about yellow and this
year for the first time I got involved a
little bit I go let me just see what's
going on Pat Benatar was in the running
Oh big time Judas Priest was in the
running up biggie smalls was in the
runnings you know Whitney Houston
Depeche Mode Nine Inch Nails I'm like
man Soundgarden that Soundgarden I go
that's a [ __ ] hell of a [ __ ] cast
that yeah you know I should I know Dave
Matthews was there or I personally hate
with all my heart with his [ __ ] best
definitely gang hangout [ __ ] voice
good I know how it works in sports were
like you have to be retired for five
years and then get like how do they
choose who's considered for the Hall of
Fame
I think you got to be in the business
for 20 or 30 years one of those two but
you can still be playing but you have to
be eligible you have to be playing for
like I think it's twenty or thirty years
one of those two 20 that might be 20
because
some of that would leave if they have
any requirement yeah
don't check yeah to see one of the
requirements to be considered for the
Rock and Roll Hall of Fame yeah
eligibility see if it's amount of Muse
and gold albums I think it's time yeah
it's time though because that's how it
bands get introduced like every few
years old they'll say such and such is
eligible now and then I it's definitely
time I just don't know what it is it's
like 25 or 30 years what makes a band
eligible for the Rockwell Hall of Fame
all right it's funny too because I bet a
lot of people don't know what it is I
mean I'm just guessing but I think
that's what it is cuz I talked to robby
krieger about it last week and he said
oh yeah they started with the fifties
bands because it was a certain amount of
time before they are eligible so you
know Buddy Holly James Brown Elvis all
those people were eligible first because
of the amount of time so what did you
think of this year it says 25 years
there it is I knew it had to be yeah 25
years that's it
little e they says they the criteria is
an influence significance of the artists
contributions right and but yeah just 25
years that part makes me furious because
it's it's they're bringing in bands now
that are let's say a Radiohead which I
love and they deserve to be in right
away but you wouldn't bring in some Nine
Inch Nails weren't in this year and and
Trent even said this himself Devo and
Kraftwerk are not in and Nine Inch Nails
is influenced heavily by Kraftwerk Devo
and an early industrial type of stuff
that those guys were doing and he's like
look I shouldn't be in before Gary Numan
Karen
and is not in the Rock and Roll Hall of
Fame you know and it's it's in Kraftwerk
and all those things that he listened to
so that's where they're making the
mistake because they're gone for as
Steve Jones explained it to me on my
podcast they're going for ticket sales
the Rock n Roll Hall of Fame get butts
into the the actual Museum and it's
really weird because you're thinking
like well you know Devo not too many
people you know they're not a marquee
thing but they are they're absolutely
huge and they influence the [ __ ] out of
you know everybody everybody like the
cars and all that new wave stuff Devo
was like the the groundbreakers in the
70s in Ohio playing that [ __ ] getting
bottles thrown at them get out of here
you queer you know like they said it was
radical they'll be playing these redneck
bars you know and they're like oh god
god no in their underwear and [ __ ]
satisfaction and people are like Boise
and Boston or Skinner you know they
throw some habits it's wild so I think
that's the mistake they make big time
that they don't get the the influencers
in first and then of course these other
bands should be in nine of snails of
course they should be but not before
Kraftwerk or Devo or you know Gary Numan
or any of those guys you know why
wouldn't be how they even get brought up
I mean how do they even get brought up I
mean somebody's got to bring them up
somebody's got to bring up crap for yeah
somebody has to bring up Devo somebody
has to bring up these type of bands that
just cuz maybe like I know that if you
hear stories all that whole grunge scene
were started by Mother Love all right
Mother Love Bone was the band that
everybody fought to be and they spawned
Pro jam and
right whatever tool but then the singer
died yeah Andrew Wood Andrew Wood that
was Cornell's roommate right Cornell's
roommate died and everything changed and
blah blah blah blah blah blah you know
[ __ ] somebody like that band be inducted
who I don't know maybe had a few albums
had minimal success right compared to
Soundgarden and Pearl Jam see that's the
trick that you have if I said Eddie
vented down right now he's gonna mention
Mother Love Bone
yep then we're going to see Mother Love
Bone and meeting somebody there yeah you
know and Cornell rest his soul if he was
alive I guarantee we'll even Kim Dayal
if you asked any of those guys you know
what do you think they'll tell ya twenty
nights that they want to see mother one
boat yeah and to figure out what their
identity was gonna be you know so I get
what you're saying that you know yeah
yeah guarantee or Cornell was still
alive with an old on let's put Mother
Love Bone in there first yeah because if
it wasn't for them there wouldn't have
been us you know you look at those bands
also they you know a definitely Sabbath
was there their blueprint also but yeah
it's I don't know it's it's a tough
thing you know people are like well
priest isn't in and it's it's you know
if you look at the history of metal
there's no real metal bands a lot of
metal bands in the Rock and Roll Hall of
Fame which is kind of trips me out
because they're basically kind of
stepping over a whole era of music that
was bigger than anything say from like
78 to like 90 metal was just ruling the
world priest you know if you look at its
like priests maiden saxon metallica
metallica is in there but maidens not
which is like what you know like i was
made not in the Rock and Roll Hall of
Fame and I'm not one of those guys that
are like well yeah how did they get
their Biggie's
molls why is he it's like well that to
me hip-hop became the new metal once NWA
and Biggie Smalls and and Snoop and all
that hit that was like that was heavy
heavy [ __ ] man that was like radical
stuff at the time how did you feel when
that came out I mean see the thing I
love them why you and I connected
musically is because you don't give a
[ __ ] now you understand the value of
Public Enemy Oh like my list the Tom
Morello Shawn he plays a whole Public
Enemy
ah it's slice is truly like the sword
because it was that influential to me
listen to it it blew my [ __ ] mom big
time and it blew his mind yeah
and they transform that into Rage
Against the Machine yep so it's just so
weird
I'm open to anything so here I have
friends who like [ __ ] that black [ __ ]
[ __ ] it I'm like you know [ __ ] that's
lunacy
what you're saying you've no idea enema
somebody tell me something bad about
Marvin Gaye one time I'm like Jeff
listen to this particular how you know
what's that one James Brown how the
Prince of Harlem or whatever something
of Harlem The Godfather or more he's got
one out that's got a weird name to it
listen to that [ __ ] out the black
something Jesus my mind started to slip
that out for Briony I look back on the
cycle get off I go on and get after you
know yeah [ __ ] you know turn me on
like I knew about this album yeah but
you know reminded me about the sound
Gerry Rocha remind me about this James
ran out well it was in the studio yeah
black Julius oh yeah black Caesar black
Caesar yeah something like that that's
just a roar yeah when you hear that you
hear Public Enemy yeah you hear whoo
tang yeah yeah you see all the
influences that that out had on them it
France there's black Caesar yeah black
Caesar black Caesar you hear Prince
Prince you hear so you know this is why
we could go on this forever this
transfer ever I mean I was very
surprised Nine Inch Nails got nominated
and yeah came out of nowhere
I'm glad they got in me to Depeche Mode
yeah love to passel of Depeche Mode
anyway I know you gonna call me Frank
but this year all the nominees I liked I
was down you know sound for Pat Benatar
I was down for Pat Benatar the ones I
didn't get and and I gotta be honest I
got a more and get t-rex oh yeah well
there's so I'm not a t-rex guy right but
they wreck they influenced the [ __ ] out
of everybody but their glam rock you
know and then you have Thin Lizzy who
I'm gonna tell you something yeah every
time I hear that [ __ ] song I want to
crash my car oh I can't take what's back
in town
can't take I want to take the car yeah
went to a [ __ ] building yeah and I
want the car though just blow up into
flames it's you know doing the movies
all the time you can't believe how fast
my arm is it is ninja speed and that
comes on the radio it's like what so I
made an some kid said some to me on
Facebook yeah he's like what do you
think you look them Lizzie and because
of that song and at the time he caught
me I was so high yeah I said I can't I
just you know I gave him like the most
honest answer and he goes that proves to
me you don't know why you're talking huh
go put on this out yeah go [ __ ] you you
know yeah yeah I can i whole way them
like talk I forgot all about that out I
love thing right see I had a friend that
used to put that out my whatever weeks
ago steel speakers yeah steel sneakers
and I was as warm about way before then
they have like a live double out yeah oh
yeah that record is so great I out
jailbreak yeah highlight the guitar on I
had a [ __ ] base to hold this part I
don't like think it's [ __ ] when they
all get into it it's gonna be jailbreak
disco
you'll break away though Punjab don't
don't let me tell you something I love
Lizzie so much you do that it makes me
furious when the DJ's play that song it
makes me feel now you know how I feel
right here have a drink on me ah I'm
gonna take the car yeah pull over and
call the DJ hoping love dies the forever
one can't why are you putting on have a
drink on me they play the same songs
from these bands it makes me crazy you
shook me all night long [ __ ] want a
shoe bison yeah the boys are back in
town Skynyrd Freebird like these bands
have living after midnight which gets me
fired up yeah and the car I think about
my old days getting dressed as [ __ ] yeah
lock putting on living at them that was
my thing living after midnight good but
these bands have I'm a dude Thin Lizzy
has a record
I love the John Sykes era which is the
last year they have a record called
renegade and it's uh it's got this song
on an angel of death oh man it is so
good and and and that live it's called
live life or still I forget what it's
called live life it's insane this Thin
Lizzy record man I used to listen that
was one of the we'd first was coming
around to the strong weed indica and my
buddy Bob dike he's to wear glasses we
called him dike takus he had this El
Camino Monte Carlo with the gents and
try axles and the super power amp you
know in the glove box and he put this
record on for life yeah my life there's
a song on there angel of death man he
put it on and I was just like this is
incredible I love Thin Lizzy all of it
but boys are back in town you know and
it's a hit song and then you know I
first heard it I love that it's like
we're talking about I don't need to hear
walk this way ever again but Aerosmith
has so many insane great deep tracks
it's unbelievable how many great
songs a sight for sore eyes last child
SOS too bad nobody's fault nobody's
fault
Avery Oswald and king queen king and
queen no more no more I could go on I
like I like the first down and the
second I like the first three albums
more than yeah like they're up there in
my top ten of my life the first three
Aerosmith downs crush of who I am dirty
yeah not perfect yeah the first time is
very raw which I like the way they taped
it to sell yet the second album is a
little bit more polished but I think for
rocks they weren't in between yeah it
took the best of both of those elements
which really nobody's fault is dirty the
bass line is dirty yeah it's really
dirty I like all that Toys in the Attic
I could live with yeah draw the line
draw the line I could live with that's
kings and queens yeah night in the ruts
night in the ruts I could live with yeah
I could put them all into the hole out
but [ __ ] those first three ah my
bread and butter till the end the time I
can't believe how I saw him master he
goes Tania and I've been listening to to
Aerosmith like seven days since now just
non-stop over and over and I'm just like
I can't believe this band actually
they're all alive there's only two bands
with original members ZZ Top and
Aerosmith and they're all alive and they
sound better than ever
why you watched him yeah to quote my
friend my dear friend Stephen villo from
the past masters so I grew up with he's
in a band a band called the past masses
he put it best to me he goes if you see
Aerosmith oh it is is all Guns & Roses
is has Guns and Roses on steroids
yeah Guns and Roses Aerosmith on
steroids yeah because of you looking
Guns and Roses it's like the layout if
you look at Aerosmith it's the same yeah
what do you call that the blue
print oh yeah for guns and row yeah you
got Joe Perry that slash that's not it's
just them yeah on steroid yeah Brad
Whitford would be the Izzy straddling
over they're keeping a quiet but he's
the killer songwriter riff player then
you've got the the frontman Steven Tyler
acts off yeah and then the baseplate
Duff McKagan Tom Hamilton you know it's
definitely isn't ending up at all yeah I
don't the same yet lanky yeah you know
it's [ __ ] crazy that there was a
blueprint for it yeah they even covered
mama Kenyan on the first EP Guns and
Roses they were all about it
and I talked to Brad Whitford about it I
told him as I watched last child which
he wrote I was watching a plane and it
was the first time it hit me last Monday
I was like oh [ __ ]
get /e he took Joe Perry's vibe but he
took Brad Whitford its plan and and Brad
said you know it's funny as slash will
tell you that straight up he'll tell you
that's what he did he took the combo and
put him together man he took the plane
to Brad and the vibe of Joe and it hit
me last week because Brad plays slash
plays like Brad you know it's that kind
of that kind of sound and then the song
right and they they're like they're
looking at Aerosmith like you and I are
looking at like say prior each time
you're writing a joke you're like this
ain't good enough
this ain't good enough and that's how
they got that Appetite for Destruction
just throwing out songs that weren't
good enough and coming at you with ten
crushers they knew you know good
songwriting if this is to like up a tie
like newsy then we're off the talking
I'll cut it out but isn't it Aerosmith
is that the one that's going on having
that issue with a drummer right now yeah
that just seems crazy like I don't I
don't know any of the story behind it
well you had a surgery so he had he
hadn't played with the original drummer
yeah yeah Joey Kraemer emo and the night
I went last Monday was his first night
back other
yeah he's back in now but he had a
physical yeah hit him do the thing yeah
it's a grueling schedule oh man you know
you paying 65 250 300 you can't sound
like [ __ ] you got a respect there I
respected it I was like Rock okay this
is what I wrote it's all about they
didn't get to become a little fun payoff
yeah because they want charity they
don't want a background drummer in the
back plan yeah they want Joey Kraemer I
understand I know people always you know
they were hitting me like hey watch yes
Brad why they locked out the drummer and
[ __ ] is like they don't just do that
it's not like one day like a [ __ ] Joey
let's just lock the door it's obviously
a reason you know and they're not gonna
come out with personal stuff like well
he had this and that and this and you
know they're not gonna do that it's it's
a lot like that Sabbath thing like I
truly believed that Bill Ward he
couldn't do that whole tour you got to
get insurance to you know ensure these
tours there's millions and millions of
dollars involved and you gotta pass
physicals and stuff and if you can't do
it nobody's gonna insure the tour he got
a heavy yeah he got really heavy and you
know his blood pressure is out of whack
a bunch of [ __ ] was out of whack and I
mean like through the longest shard
though they were petrified every day
yeah you know my blood pressure walking
in there was a 180 ohh 140 well the
doctor would have to lie yeah
sit there for ten minutes before he won
the playing field they are really
[ __ ] worried about me yeah well
insurance is involved oh it's crazy I
don't [ __ ] around a liability insurance
and why they go on the road just in case
I just got it what was with me their
issue they fall down the stairs yeah you
know I'm saying everything's covered
because you need all that [ __ ] yeah man
from people all knowing you know it's
big business man and these bands have
been it's not like a a band that's five
years in where you're like these are
brothers man you cut your brother out
it's like by then it's like no this is a
comp
it's banned you don't want to look at it
that way but it's a company it's a
business it's a full enterprise there's
other people involved and you you know
carting this thing around America
somebody gets sick died because they
weren't you know what the best part
about comedy is the first ten years so
well it's not a business yeah exactly if
you leave it like that you'll be fine
yeah if you tie yourself this is not a
business this is just me striving to be
the funniest person in the world it's a
different mindset and that's the mindset
you should have toy your first ten years
don't think of it as a business it's an
investment
it's your investment instead of taking
dollars into your pocket and invest them
in coca-cola and wishing the stock stays
up you're investing in yourself that
you're gonna be healthy the stock is
going to stay up and you know that the
end of the year you never be that much
better yeah nobody wants to hire you
right now yeah you don't have 15 minutes
right now but in a year watch my smoke
and that year goes by and again like you
said you don't think something happens
or something always does because maybe
it's that third year well that's that
year that you did snaps and all of a
sudden now you're featuring yeah so the
first ten years it's not a business
then it became a business like the
Eagles right hate the Eagles for example
they were the [ __ ] number one band
for all those years they played that
last show right here in Long Beach they
drew guitars on each other they hate
each other yeah they took a hiatus they
said they asked them for years would you
get back together hell has to freeze
over somebody showed up with a number
hope and said hell froze over yeah gonna
[ __ ] pay you this amount of money yeah
yeah [ __ ] everything the first band that
said [ __ ] it we're gonna have to charge
$250 a ticket yeah and guess what they
get together in a studio everybody pulls
up in their families the Mercedes Benz
and then comes Don whatever
John I only know the other Don look at
the great big world greatest guitar
players of our day Feldman oh yeah
yeah oh yeah with a z28 t-shirt on that
says you know che guevara yeah all of
them got her loud Gucci shirts on yeah
saina pants yeah and he shows up a long
hair t-top Mifflin still and they're
like oh yeah we just got 250 million
dollars to do a tour you got a haircut
yeah and get a suit this became a
business yeah
and he couldn't accept it now and
eventually whatever what happened went
back and he's not an abandoned him oi
could it be oh well we became employees
or whatever it became a business yeah
well you got a $250 ticket yeah look
your best you gotta be your best yeah we
can't have you up there looking like a
[ __ ] dude salutes yeah you know if
it's if if I had it my way I'd have six
openness with me on the rug yeah I got a
great heart I would have six or five
openers would be on the road and have a
great time go eat and write together and
stuff like that but I know that I would
diss the audience all yeah too much the
audience doesn't want to see six [ __ ]
Oprah yeah you know I would loved I love
bringing you on the road with me I wish
Lee gets dirty so I could we guess what
my audience likes a woman in front of me
better
yeah because while the girls by their
boyfriends tickets and then the girls
are like what the [ __ ] it's been an hour
dick yeah I was a dick but for me yeah
yeah it's a business yeah it's not
personal this is a business absolutely
everybody's gonna be tip-top Magoo and
this even want from me yeah this even
had went for me you know you have to
dress up a little bit you have to look
presentable well I used to open up for
Rogan I wouldn't shave yeah you know you
could see the bags on the mines I had
scabs on my face from picking my face on
my dorm blow oh man we know you can't
sell a $10,000 car with a ten dollar
presentation yeah you know so this is
what happens in all these things it
becomes a business
and with Joey Kraemer there's been
plenty of bands that you got to look at
the person and go this guy's not gonna
[ __ ] make it I know people are never
honest about it observing it's not gonna
happen he's not gonna make it he's got a
drug problem he's had for 20 years we're
going on 20 years he's worse than ever
yeah and now you want to pull him out
for another [ __ ] 40 city tour why are
you doing this there's a law of
diminishing returns
you better have Rudy Sarzo on speed dial
yeah and hope he's not busy because this
guy's not gonna make the [ __ ] thought
yeah you could tell you know it's like
when yeah why would you if [ __ ] I
wake up on Thursday morning and I got a
hundred and three fever and I got a
sold-out weekend in Columbus I have to
think like a businessman okay there's
two options I have hey I get my [ __ ]
[ __ ] ass up
I take [ __ ] to town laws and the
[ __ ] whatever I get on a plane risk
getting more germs to an already down
immune system go to Columbus go up on
stage
coughing sneeze yeah the show's a 65%
because your confidence needs them like
I'm a Mook now you come back now guess
what you got bronchitis and then
heightened to a light pneumonia yeah
because you got open to all those
[ __ ] Germans but you got your check
but guess what that pneumonia now
prevents you from going on the road for
four weeks
yeah do you follow me yeah grabbed one
to miss for you grab one to miss for
craze the same thing happens now like I
wake up on Thursday morning suddenly
right go go go but we can't do it hasn't
happened knocked on wood yeah I'm
telling you the truth because I don't
want to be in your town sniffling
onstage with a cold then the worst thing
you could do is open yourself up on a
plane the Holland's are filthy oh those
planes are filthy oh [ __ ] stop there's a
carnivore [ __ ] god whatever going on
around yeah I flew the last two weeks
I've flown people come right off that
plane and you bought it it was priceless
thanks Brian no
they're in business to spread that [ __ ]
yeah and he [ __ ] day now and he
[ __ ] day now it's gonna start out
with some airport so knock on wood but
that's the thing we're going back to
Joey Kraemer yeah called back to what we
do there's a day you decide when this
becomes a business yep yeah you have the
right to call this a business and also
you have to earn that right to call this
a [ __ ] business yeah yeah I'm the CEO
of what I do what do you do I get on
stage eight times a week eight nights a
week ever there's only seven I got stage
a double yeah I know what you're talking
about
you know yeah and that's I know it's
like people are just complaining us ya
know and I mean they just like to sit
around and complain like god no Joey
Kraemer or Oh G&R would know no you know
Steven Adler didn't make a difference
ya didn't make a difference couldn't
even tell they weren't that yeah I've
seen the greatest singers and people
missing from bands of all time
she sat right there where you were a
month ago and I told that husband did
something nobody could do and that was
Phil [ __ ] Ozzy Osbourne shoes that
was very [ __ ] hard to do yeah it was
you know when do I don't know do joining
Sabbath was a bit more shocking than
Hagar replacing near los yeah this was
the end of a [ __ ] era this was
9-ounce people knew who black sabbath
was oh yeah when deal took that stage in
Philadelphia I'll never forget going
this guy he might get shot yeah yeah no
they might send ciancia rounds brother
the guy who shot ya shoot the I Fabio
was not gonna make the tour Wow
I really thought some using a bazooka
him yeah you know and this guy went out
there amongst the [ __ ] signs bringing
back Ozzy when I went to see him in
Philly that was 20 [ __ ] you signs yeah
bring back Ozzy yeah he went out there
was a little more Luke your fingers and
won him over
won them over and bang that out
bang them out of them left and started
his band with Vivian camp
oh yeah and you gotta respect that I
told I go you don't know how many times
I don't want to get up on stage and I
think back up him going up on stage like
the second night of the tour in Philly
yeah he felt like you're replacing Ozzy
[ __ ] around yeah
you know Sammy Hagar's replacing [ __ ]
Rock Roth you know these are bad news
that some bands don't even work a look
at when [ __ ] what's-his-name when
they replaced a chubby dude from Motley
Crue oh yeah wet john korabik
yeah they should work at all now it
didn't work at all no not at all not
even they weren't even going for it at
least my generation gave you a chance
ha ha my generation the seventies we
gave you yeah we'll go one time you know
that's how yes started yeah yes yeah
like the first band and two people left
and all some people are we're not gonna
say yes yeah either the moment was born
yeah oh where do they call to members
members some other [ __ ] yeah what do
they call it I know um man oh [ __ ]
hate that they call John Walton no no no
they called [ __ ] Asia Asia Asia man I
don't know who guys left to guys that's
what I don't there's a lot of people get
pissed off at that listen look at
Leonard Skinner
how many people do you think we're rich
lean left from let it's get it yeah yeah
what do you think is in there [ __ ]
eight of them died yeah toured it for
twenty years a bunch of people that were
toothless yeah they got the grandson in
there nephew it works man yeah if that
was one band I refused to ever go see
you go without without wrong
I was like a kid and you know that's
right I tell people if you don't if you
are complaining just don't buy the
ticket it's really that easy you could
sit home watch YouTube of old footage of
Skynyrd and enjoy life like look at the
Skinner that one we loved and the green
and just enjoy it but these people got
there's just [ __ ] it's like just
don't buy a ticket I don't see how you
get that worked up it's crazy go see a
new band go see a new band you know go
see Marcus King go see rival sons go see
a new band and go this is my band now
[ __ ] that other stuff they don't got
original dudes I'm seeing this band go
see that that's what I tell people all
the time you living in a dream you're
calm the hair metal tumbleweeds
they're blowing around sunset what
happened [ __ ] man used to be good
it's like it's still good when I first
moved to LA yeah there was still guys on
Sunset with tight black pain oh yeah
yeah Ralph's rock'n'roll Ralph's yeah
getting the Top Ramen
I'm totally [ __ ] lost yeah and you
know like oh my god I love that I love
music I love the 80s
I love 2020 I love the 90s but you know
I love the 70s I'm not a guy that it's
just like it was good for two years
those are people that just use music as
a memory of when they didn't have bills
or a divorce or anything it's just a
time machine that takes them back
they're like this is good music is like
now that's just when you didn't have
student loans yeah that's all that is a
couple weeks ago we had Josh Adam eyes
on he's got the show on Spotify Sam
Cooke yeah the boardwalk put the other
Jam I told that to different people
saying and we came to a conclusion but I
said to my view they heard the platters
no yeah he's like I don't know he time I
played the platters and that night I
went all and started playing
like blown the [ __ ] away
yeah like crying you know you got the
magic touch
ah when the Twilight is gone
you come into my heart yeah yeah I'm
here in my heart you will stay Wow
tremendous for ya my prayer this is
1950s these are poor black kids in the
[ __ ] 50 killing it just and their
voices were pure listen for the tapings
they knew how to [ __ ] record in those
days oh man they without a [ __ ]
record you listening you're like oh my
god it's [ __ ] crystal clear Oh Motel
according yeah hits hits field well but
I went to that studio all that [ __ ] as I
could it was like the size of this room
you know they're in there recording all
those hundreds of hits that just sound
incredible that those fifties recordings
just the temptations when you hear that
mugger it just comes on it's clean
it's super warm lean yeah [ __ ] they
throw that stuff yeah I love music man I
did Terrell I could [ __ ] music for
[ __ ] how was it it's amazing how much
music I listen to in the days oh and
when my wife tells me she's gotta leave
for now yeah I could really crank it oh
my god I [ __ ] cranked it oh yeah I
know that God like the universal for
three hours yeah it's [ __ ] loud some
air guitar you got some Joey air guitar
huh yeah Walt day yeah yeah had almost
[ __ ] ah
I am a a guitar in my mind yeah yeah
yeah you know it's funny so I told you
when I first moved to Boulder I moved to
the apartment you know a four-bedroom
apartment somebody else rented each room
college students yeah there was a
Japanese
yeah you kept telling me I worked under
the Sun for that money go [ __ ] yourself
yeah it was a [ __ ] but the white guy yeah
air guitar contest and those two idiots
was sitting on Friday nights they would
sit and every night and that guy would
do a guitar concerts in the little room
well I'm gonna have to kill all three of
them
oh my god I'm not there [ __ ] I go
downstairs to hear two doors down the
chubby girl next door that would buy
weed I [ __ ] her in the alley a couple
times and these three idiots are in
their living room air guitaring cool
with sickness splitting a six-pack ah
watching the idiot do air guitar [ __ ]
unless something kill this isn't freaks
no I want to kill this is a breaks
eventually I hide the Japanese kid to
cook for me the Japanese kicked it cooks
I give him like a small 40
yeah well fathers get some steak for me
and you and he would cook everything I
was helping him up yeah yeah Ivan his
parents didn't want to send the money
you didn't know what to do he came to me
crying when I don't know what to do my
parents they don't money and I'm uh-huh
I can't pimp him up I didn't know
anybody if it was New York I'm gonna had
him out this I can pick o Porto Ricans I
thank you for the Bronx nobody knows
nothing ah but I didn't know anybody in
Colorado so I just said you cook and he
did cook Wow cook man hell I would make
them make a little beef dishes we've got
our falfa's together that's the whole
foods a boulder at the time yeah yeah
yeah yeah the meat was a little bit more
expensive but it was [ __ ] good but
it's just when you remind me of a guitar
a guitar since I was I think in the
eighth grade I used a guitar Ted Nugent
free-for-all huh
cover the cover and then put on double
live gonzo and a guitar that cover the
cover and then put on the Eagles a Hotel
California and I could [ __ ] a guitar
victim of love like nobody
good oh oh
are you [ __ ] but we might have to
have you air guitar at the Bon Scott
trivia I may do it this is out there
Angus Annette I made do we think we
another Hannibal together is going on a
Tuesday you're not even high what the
[ __ ] that'd be so great it's my birthday
tomorrow with 57 yelled at him before I
got 57 years old
you I'm 57 you dad 60 this [ __ ]
[ __ ] should have two broads eating
each other out right now for his father
and me his eyes are closed you even
think about they didn't think I'm not
even a little gift for his uncle Joey
might miss put I don't want you to buy a
gift I want you to be creative quash
good I want to come here you to tell me
and your dad to wait downstairs you had
a surprise and we come up here and
ayahuasca bleep playing with a monkey
while you had your pipe in the mouth
just to show you me and your dad were
the bosses I do you impressed me today
no my dad you can impressed me today
you're gonna have a threesome wait for
us here two chicks looking yes all
today's young and you tell me I was
waiting to get here and for deemed
already go please not let me in the
office today threesome Lee the gate will
open your father's here where's Lee told
me to come down and we knock and you say
call [ __ ] yourselves well three years
I'm getting my dick sucked
it's my birthday hey I'd probably knock
and go you know one yeah [ __ ] all right
let him roll I still get three [ __ ]
broads for your dad tonight
yeah maybe thinks like I'm joking
clothes down here you should be setting
all this up yeah I remember you find
three [ __ ] but nowhere nowhere you
know you got really fun
yeah yeah if anybody knows you know you
know everything you know everything you
know apps lis dog horn an app gets goes
to jail cuz there's a text you can code
from one Escobar gave your parents
clothes
what are you texted what are you talking
about so you texted me you want to meet
them to talk to them at Wow how much for
an hour of math yeah talking code
hundred dollars I had was 300 haha
and she walked out the back door that
means she let me [ __ ] you in the air
oh come on you gotta learn how to say
this alright I hear you paint houses
yeah and I do dry work also that means I
[ __ ] bury the body uh-huh
think you'll end up too well for him
yeah things didn't end up too well for
him that's that's why we dog there's a
minute leave the apartment they get some
crabs on your bed what do you can't go
get some excitement one last time you
found the crab anywhere close to your
body why do I want to have sex crabs
jumping out my eyeballs you have some on
your resume your resume is blank window
chlamydia get your comedy guide yeah
Thank You doc and give it shine you dick
once a month a month [ __ ] I can't
believe 157 guys 57 dared rubber turning
18 and I'm having a party for me and
[ __ ] dad Tampa
[ __ ] they were blowin [ __ ] Kong I
hammered my friend Louie Hernandez was
pissing in the toilet he was puking in
the toilet ah I'll never forget I was
dis [ __ ] up I just opened up the
bathroom and my friend Louise head was
in the toilet I go Louie excuse me I
pulled his head back east like this oh
and I peed right the front of him with
his head back Oh
music man [ __ ] cuz I made him suck my
dick oh yeah put his nose he gave me a
flash moustache that was just in the
toilet I just comedy he's my brother can
never said joke Lee I know but it was
just so funny that I did he was passed
out with his head
oh man in the toilet seat first you to
the side is always how many people had
piston that back ah and I just went
pulled his head back
I just rested I put my dignity I was
like good out of disrespect I didn't
want him to get hit with no [ __ ] no
splash no splash nosepiece flash and I
[ __ ] him let loose and then when I put
his head right back like nobody knew and
he stayed there till we left the party
oh man they [ __ ] body first ah what
are you gonna do for your birthday going
out I'm doing the store tonight yep you
know no no we gotta get some steaks I'm
look at the haircut you wanna get some
steaks this week I gotta get in shape I
gotta do something macho I look good at
power like the last couple weeks takes
that it's clean clean
[ __ ] need to look sharp by March 8th oh
man tip-top ago I gotta do some [ __ ] I
look good for the camera yeah I check I
trying to lose like five for the ac/dc
concert oh yeah yeah I just wanted this
one ever cuz that's a that's like an
hour and a half a singin a
want to be like I'm hitting the
treadmill like hard then out bike
treadmill cardio cuz you know when I did
it when I was 50 I realized that's when
I had diabetes the first like I didn't
know I had it at the time but I remember
after I did the show I sang the show for
like an hour and then got my cars
driving on say well something's wrong
with me yeah I was really that first
time you realized yeah why I knew
something was up I couldn't sleep or
whatever you know I was laying in bed
like I school I thought I was just
exhausted from you know putting that
show together but when I looked back on
it now I'm like that was the first night
cuz I just [ __ ] I remember my buddies
were in the car in the backseat they
were talking and I was just like shut up
in my head you know cuz I was like
something was wrong it was wild
so I like to be in total shape for that
thing man it's an hour and a half of
singing when you don't sing everyday
that's that's a groomer you using
different muscles on your body and now
I'm gonna have to sing it kind of still
cuz the neck I can't be up there Rocking
I'm like I'm like the old rocker now at
the neck surgery like Tom Araya from
Slayer he had to go get some neck
surgery he never got the head bang again
crazy but he said he's saying better
than ever he goes yeah I'm not all
winded from head banging now I'm just up
there killing it you know so crazy your
musical enthusiasm is so contagious yeah
man talk music it's [ __ ] contain
[ __ ] love it my brother man next
Friday we're the [ __ ] Viva Las Vegas
oh it's gonna be great
Treasure Island one show oh and then out
I was hoping that you could hook us up
with tickets or something sadly man but
there's nothing there's nothing oh no
what a bummer I wish the Aerosmith was
playing the next night we would be in
heaven heaven nothing I looked to see if
there was a comedian maybe I want to see
ya watch yeah
there's nothing let's say I'm coming
home on Saturday morning with Treasure
Island like I'm excited I got a couple
of work outside to
before I go you know yep I like what I'm
doing now I had no pressure comedy
whatever comes out and I'm doing better
sets and I've ever had what I really
really want to try new stuff I tried out
order at the store and I bombed yeah it
really doesn't matter yeah yeah it's my
[ __ ] backyard really doesn't matter
anymore
you know I'm gonna give you the best
show I got I'm writing so yeah I'm
really glad I haven't felt this
confident in a long time when I'm like
[ __ ] takes 29 years to get confidence I
only got 19 more years yeah okay my knee
is to [ __ ] fully get confident that
you could fall back on stuff yeah like I
could fall back on a story or something
not going my way yeah like now all that
stuff all those little avenues fall into
[ __ ] place you know yeah yes the
[ __ ] journey of life is beautiful I
uh
I love it [ __ ] in 1985 I had dinner by
myself for my birthday yeah like just a
the enchanted Lilly Chinese restaurant
oh man wall-e New Jersey I was 23 years
old I can't describe to you the feeling
I had that night
I had enough money for the Chinese
dinner a bag of refo la Carvel milkshake
no [ __ ] that said 85 1985 living in a
hotel down the corner one of those
[ __ ] crack hotels I was robbing gas
stations pretty much you know like I was
in between yeah doing stupid [ __ ] and
that's what I keep thinking about the
last two days that's why I was how
lonely I felt in that Chinese restaurant
that night at eight o'clock eaten I near
birthday myself 1985 like that Jimmy
Conway died from Goodfellas he died on
February 19 1985 oh you are good fellows
at the end yeah and I go in myself holy
[ __ ] he died on the loneliest birthday
ever
Oh his was his day was worse yeah
oh man it was just [ __ ] horrible but
to think that guys I thought I was gonna
be dead at 37 yeah man you know yeah I
thought that at this age I'd be living
in somebody's backyard somebody who had
pity on me we charged like 400 bucks for
rent yeah I didn't think they'd have a
daughter I think I'd be did you just
sold out the [ __ ] Chicago theater it's
it's not even that it's just taught of
being alive being functional yeah and
not being wanted by the cops or not
having somebody look for me I never
thought that I would have that peace of
mind I think how I live for you is that
was that uncut jammed lifestyle the
Attic till now and it's like two
different [ __ ] worlds you know I
never thought that so whatever you're
going through in your life believe in
yourself that greener pastures come
you're gonna suffer yeah I'm not just
gonna hand it to you you gonna have to
put in the [ __ ] work and get dirty
and you know you might even get the
carnivore disease on the way yeah that's
the matter once you get to that place
where you thought about you know and
it's nothing and you know what the best
thing is this is not about selling out
the Chicago theater or having money in
the bank nothing this is but just about
genuinely being happy
absolutely annually loving my wife
loving the [ __ ] the house you know I
like staying home a peace of mind just
success is what you want if you want a
boat were the two chicks on it
that's your success go for it yeah
that's a success I wanted in the
beginning that never got me anyway when
I just went to for being happy then
everything else fell into place
so that's truth right there I see your
happiness I see the pictures last week
of you and all and though with the gay
ghost you know you even took a picture
knows a gate goes by
Oh bites today
my mom came to the gig but where's your
mom live she was about an hour outside
Orlando so she finally got to see me do
comedy it's in my Instagram she showed
up she reviewed the show and you know
it's funny to think you know my mom
probably when she heard our starting
comedy I'm like 44 she was probably
going like oh no you know what's going
on with my son is it going crazy and
there it is ten years later I'm in
Orlando with Marin at this theater and
she's there and I had a great set thank
God marriage like a lot of people bomb
in front of their parents yeah you
killed it thank God you know because
then they're like oh yeah good show
honey yeah but it was great it was great
to see her you know and seen her in a
while and she never seen me do comedy
because when I started she was out here
she came out but I was doing spots you
know open mics and it's like I don't
want to bring her to the open mics or
I'm doing like 1:00 a.m. spots and she's
in bed by then so she didn't see me do
comedy she saw Cohan and when I did
Conan but to come to a theater with her
friend and see like smoke and set you
know it was a great set that was awesome
my brother it's always a pleasure to see
you now I love you dude happy birthday
yeah I thought about who I can have on
today and make me happy so crazy you
have Steve Simona both you yeah see
Simone's making port on Friday so boom
you're coming over the house we're gonna
order some Sicilian pizzas from your
favorite place stop poking me
no did you resist this you those highs
just they're watching you all right what
the [ __ ] I'm [ __ ] 30 years older than
you see this running fun I take next
no you guys you guys went light today -
compared to like usually it's a couple
hits is it yeah I didn't want to no
demon one of the barbiturates oh he's
got a oh I gotta Barbie oh she's coming
in here she's kind of mean yeah when
they put it in your IV it's a new form
of therapy
Wow right the UM put our feet up so
everything you're doing is tested and
approved intact this is solve the back
of the trucks all clinics the hospital
they give us a ketamine drip we take
Duncan with us yeah I have a good day
for three days for your [ __ ]
who don't know now you know Friday the
28th I think it is it doesn't matter cuz
the months got 29 days yeah figure it
out it's a Chinese you knew you a year
to read watch that [ __ ] anyway next
Friday night [ __ ] treasure [ __ ]
island 8:00 p.m.
Dean dull Rizzi uncle Joey [ __ ] going
[ __ ] bananas next week I'm excited
about Vegas I can't wait they got a good
open turkey sandwich over that the
Treasure Island yeah I got reefer
heavy-duty showing up we got everything
so if you're not doing anything then the
next day I have is March 27th in Santa
Barbara California at the Arlington
[ __ ] Peter I gotta do some
things in March so if you need to see me
in the next two months that's the only
places you'll see me real quick I want
to give a shout out the church is
brought to you by as usual on it the
best I'll see them in Austin Texas
[ __ ] in two months
tremendous listen go to inot calm my now
shroom tech is big right now the immune
would all these [ __ ] Chinese people
walk around breathing around
stroke I would have immune [ __ ] I
would have immune whatever the [ __ ]
is all over
rumbling it bad tub don't know I haven't
had an egg roll in 11 days I'm
boycotting I'm done it's all over
haven't gone for a massage you do your
own corn Dental acupuncturist - suck my
dick it's over I'm running with the Jew
chick again
I can't risk one of those [ __ ]
carnivore needles in me and I'm saying
yes you know I'm turning purple I'm
doing karate boom I don't need that [ __ ]
and neither do you go - aah - calm right
now take a look at the shroom tech
immune take 18 of them and if you around
anybody anybody that's kind of [ __ ]
that eats lizards or whatever boom those
[ __ ] were eating bats who eats
a [ __ ] bat why do you do this to me
why do you make me [ __ ] sick to my
stomach and eat it back anyway shroom
tech immune don't worry about nothing
take four of them you could [ __ ] have
it the China guy breathe on the 18 times
you'll be fine if you go on a cruise you
deserve to die you dumb [ __ ] [ __ ] you
[ __ ] anyway go to adam.com right
now present Church and get 10% off you
ought to deliver it right to the crib
who's better than uncle Joey nobody I
want to thank Dean dollar Izzie I wanna
think the Christ killer but most
importantly I want to thank you
[ __ ] savages for always having
our back and for loving us don't forget
next Friday Treasure Island [ __ ] stay
black have a great week
see you Monday ready to go tip-top
[ __ ] Magoo Oh saluting the flag
like you [ __ ] on it stay black be
safe love your Uncle Joe